i started doing these channel updates a
few months back and i find that they're
a useful way for me to
review what i what i've gotten
accomplished over the last month compare
it to what i intended to accomplish
and to
think about what i'm going to be doing
over the coming month
sketch out some projects set some goals
it also helps my viewers have some idea
of what it is that i'm i'm up to
in part because some of the the things
i'm involved with are not happening on
youtube you can see some reflections of
them
on youtube but many of them are
happening out in the much wider world
not necessarily on on the net
i will be including some links in the
description
of this video to some of the things that
i'm talking about if they've they've got
useful linked material for you so
what happened in october
i didn't get as much accomplished as i'd
hoped but that seems to be the running
pattern for most months
i went to the society for ancient greek
philosophy where i presented my paper on
anger justice and injustice in aristotle
and it was it was well received i didn't
actually
read the entire paper i summarized it
and i have a podcast
available of it
which i'll talk a little bit more about
later on because i have a idea of what i
might do with it this month
if you're interested in it you can find
the handouts the podcast linked to here
and
that's enough to say about that
um
i also did an insight radio spot for for
patrick mccarty's show this is something
new i've done a few internet radio shows
before
with theology matters now this is a new
venue
and patrick mccarty works out of chicago
where he's been a
freelancer professor doing a lot of
different things for for numbers of
years but he's got this very interesting
show where he gets some really
interesting topics and guests and so i
was very happy to be on the show he
asked me to talk
about hegel's master slave dialectic and
that's where we started and very quickly
it spread into a lot of other
discussions and ended up focusing
towards the end of the show very much on
the current state of america and even
western
education and the role that technology
plays for good or for bad often for both
at the same time
in american education and and the
generational differences you know we
talk about digital natives and
and
the way in which the web is reworking
our our habits our ways of approaching
material
and thinking things through so that was
a very interesting conversation
i'm continuing teaching my my courses
at marist college i've got two classes
one is an intro to philosophy class
which is focused specifically on the
question
of love friendship and desire
and so that's been proceeding
as as it should you know students are
learning we're discussing things in
class i'm not getting as much discussion
out of them as i'd like but that's
fairly par for the course for for marist
students they're not the most talkative
bunch they are writing good papers so
that's that's good
my ethics class is continuing on its
normal path where
we plowed through utilitarian moral
theory and went into
deontological moral theories
focusing on epictetus wd ross and then a
lot of time on kant
and we're now moving into the ethics of
care before we we finish up by going
back to virtue ethics with aristotle and
then a little bit of thomas aquinas and
a little bit of aleister mcintyre at the
end of the semester
so
that's a good place to segue into videos
as usual i've been recording videos in
some of my courses specifically the
intro to philosophy because that's all
new material
so i've i've got some videos this month
that i've recorded we finished up with
aristotle but i had some things from
nickel mccain ethics book 10 which i
hadn't covered before
um
looked at epicurus and i hadn't taught
the vatican sayings of epicurus before i
taught other other texts of his and so
we incorporated those and we talked
specifically about the nature of
friendship and how it fit into the good
life
then we spent three
no two class sessions on cicero's on
friendship a classic text
not only an ancient philosophy but one
that had incredible influence on
medieval philosophy and medieval
theology so we looked at that that's a
really fun text to teach and then we
actually tackled and we only spent three
class sessions on this even though it
deserves you know a whole semester
augustine's confessions
and that that we just finished up with
by the end of the month
so
there's course videos on those that you
can find
i also managed to shoot some core
concept videos in my ethics class i use
my
class where i've got videos on that
particular material to focus in
on particular issues particular topics
particular concepts
and so i've got some on bentham and i
also shot a few on mill and i shot some
on wd ross
i didn't get much done on the
existentialism course front
unfortunately i only managed to get one
video on lev shestov
shot so that's a bit of a disappointment
because i wanted to be further along
with with that work
um
but you know it's a good video i i
really enjoyed researching it and and
shooting it and editing it and putting
it together it's a little bit longer
than my usual one-hour videos it's about
an hour and 20 minutes
and it talks about chestov's approach to
particular
philosophical movements and issues
i have been blogging not as much as i
would have liked to this month and
hopefully that'll that'll improve this
coming month
um
i made a decision or at least came to a
decision
about my main blog which i've had for a
number of years called orexis
dianoetique
and that blog
i
i've usually been just writing
pieces for it which are fairly long
sometimes they're in serial
form you know part one part two part
three the longest i ever did with that
was a a piece on anselm which went seven
parts
and
i decided what i needed to do with it
because i've got four different blogs
and i'm actually
incomprehensibly still thinking about
using another one who's whose domain i
reserved a while back
um
i thought i needed to consolidate things
i didn't
i considered actually closing some of
the other blogs like virtue ethics
digest and sadler's existentialist
updates and the new one that i started
heavy metal philosopher
um
but i i didn't do that instead what i
decided to do is if i write something on
those blogs and i'm trying to maybe
write
two entries per month on those blogs
i put a short
i put a link to it and a short little
summary of it on my main blog because
that way people
if they're only interested in following
one of those blogs they can they can
follow the arrexistino etk blog
and they can stay on top of what i'm
doing and i you know i've been doing
this for a while as well which is
putting
um
short blurbs or links or connections to
some of the talks that i'm giving some
of the invited um occasions radio shows
pic you know whatever it is that i
happen to be doing that has some sort of
uh public philosophical
aspect to it
so
rex is doing tk the entries are in some
ways getting shorter but they're getting
more frequent which is really the way it
ought to be for blogs
and i'm gonna still continue writing
these long entries from time to time
when i have the time when i can carve
out the time
but i think if you're following that
blog and i invite everybody to follow
that blog you're going to see a lot more
entries you know one to two per week
maybe even three per week if i get
particularly ambitious
i also got quite a bit of writing done
which was gratifying on aristotle and
anger which is the topic of one of the
books that i'm currently writing
and that feels very good
you know i spend a lot of time
producing video content and course
content and i spent a lot of time this
month for example developing handouts
which are also available
online in in my academia.edu profile i
should have mentioned that before
so i spent a lot of time doing that
stuff
and that takes away time because there's
only so many hours in the day
from
some of the stuff that i used to get
to do a lot more of which is to do
straight out
hunker down
high theory academic writing
i've got several different book projects
going on and and for a while i've been
kind of
how would you put it
not so much upset
and not depressed
um
but
it's been sort of a drag not getting
that much done on them you know feeling
like i've got these projects that are
just sort of hanging out there so it was
nice to actually get some solid work
done on my aristotle and anger book um
hopefully this coming month i'll get to
work on that and also my handsome and
more theory book
so that's a good point to turn to what's
going on in november
next week i have a talk that i'm giving
at marist college it was originally
going to be scheduled as a lunch talk
hosted by the medieval renaissance
studies program
but
we realize that it's a longer talk it's
more involved it's it's not something
that lends itself to such a short format
so the catholic studies program is
actually hosting it um
at marist college
this coming tuesday tuesday night 6 30
and what is the talk about it's about
how the eight capital vices became the
seven deadly sets a lot of people don't
know that the seven deadly sins have a
long history and that
the list that we currently have is not
the original list
not to say that there's anything wrong
with the current list it's just that it
has a rich
much more
complex history than a lot of people
realize originally there were eight
capital vices
envy was not actually one of them
so how did we get from eight vices
to seven
sins well that's a long story and it
involves a lot of different characters
ranging from these these monks like uh
vegas ponticus and john cassian and all
these abbotts out in the egyptian and
syrian deserts
uh palestinian deserts too all the way
to
um
thomas aquinas and bonaventure and
eventually people like like st john of
the cross
so
and there's other people intervening in
the middle like like gregory the great
so it's it's a it's a good talk i've
given it
in other forms before
um and i'm really looking forward to
to talking with the the marist students
about this
maybe some faculty as well
i'm also going to be doing another
insight radio
this time it's going to be about
aristotle and anger i'm gonna be the the
main guest and we're gonna talk about
what i've been researching for oh it's
been about six seven years since i first
started researching aristotle's views on
anger and thinking that i needed to
originally write an article about it and
then realized that i had to write write
a book about it
um i'm going to continue blogging and
i've already said enough about that so i
don't think i need to say anything more
um other than if you want to see the
sort of stuff that i'm i'm doing take a
look at arrexis dno ntk
um
i'm also going to be doing
and i meant to get to this this last
month and didn't get to it i'm finally
hopefully going to be producing some
lessons in this new online platform
called curious
which allows professors to
not only upload videos but but include
little mini quizzes
and resources
and all sorts of things like that to to
create a much more enhanced
um educational
experience for students you know people
have been saying about my videos that
i'm providing an online education
for free
and
whenever i see that i think to myself
well i'm not really providing an online
education per se i'm providing elements
of an online education i'm you know
providing these lectures and i go up to
the board and i i talk about things and
sometimes i link to to useful resources
and and i have a lot of stuff available
online if people are interested in that
sort of thing handouts you know articles
that i've written
um
but there's more to education than
simply having the text and having
lecture videos to to watch
there there needs to be a bit more
interactivity you know the idea of
having quizzes where a student can can
assess how well they understand the
material
writing prompts
reflection questions to think about
handouts that they can use to make sense
of things links to other
resources that they might find useful
like encyclopedia entries that are
online or
projects or discussion groups that's all
that makes it a much more powerful
package and that's what curious is doing
and curious does charge for some of the
lessons pretty minimal cost which also
makes it very attractive
and i have three lessons in there
already about jean-paul sartre those are
sort of trial things we want to see
whether whether this sort of thing could
work
i'm going to be uploading lessons this
month hopefully
it's maybe a little ambitious but
hopefully
on plato's apology credo and euthyphro
so we're going to give that a shot
um there's another educational platform
that i'm i'm pretty involved with called
learnest
where i create courses that
give you
links to the online texts online
versions of the text
some of my videos
handouts that i've developed
links to useful encyclopedia entries or
things like that
and i've got about
12 courses in learnest right now ranging
from cicero to plato to
aristotle to to
kant and bentham and i'm going to be
my goal is to actually
add
three courses to learners per month i
want to be
using these educational platforms to
make it possible for people
who
either can't go to college
because of the economy or
you know
what's going on with their lives or who
are in college and are not getting that
much out of it
or who want to you know brush up on
things
you know they they have to take so many
courses they're not able to go back to
do
do philosophy courses i want to develop
these resources within these online
platforms to make that possible
and this is all sort of trial and error
stuff
it uses my youtube channel but it uses a
lot of other resources as well like my
academia.edu profile where i upload
handouts and other other documents
anyway learnest curious that's what i'm
going to be working with this month i
might i might start looking at a few
other
platforms as well but but i'm trying to
take it slow because i have a tendency
to
bite off more than i can chew at times
um
what else
oh
videos what am i going to be doing this
month with videos well i'm still
teaching the intro course so
what we've got coming up this month is
really interesting stuff i just uploaded
a video on
abelard and eloise's letters which
reveal this
amazing story of of love passion revenge
taking
vows that paradoxically bind them
to this this terrible fate
anyway if you haven't seen it take a
look at that video and and read those
letters they're very very interesting
things
so i i uh uploaded that the next week
and a half we're going to be looking at
thomas aquinas on love so we're looking
at
some parts of the summatio logica
discussing divine love discussing love
as a passion or human emotion and then
discussing the virtue of charity and how
it plays out
uh after that we're going to be looking
at the correspondence between rene
descartes
and princess elizabeth
a brilliant you know
contemporary of descartes who actually
prompted him to write one of his books
and we're going to read that book
afterwards the passions of the soul
if we have the time we're going to try
to get to
bits of kierkegaard's works of love i'm
not sure if we'll actually get to that
i will be doing some
additional core concept videos most
likely i have some
on kant that i shot i've got some more
to shoot on mill
we've got some some aristotle ones
specifically on new you know discussions
of the virtues like we're going to look
at the virtue of courage
and the virtue of um
uh
good humor and things like that in my my
class
um
i'm not quite sure how much will
actually get done with those core
concepts i don't want to promise too
much but i will be shooting quite a
quite a few
there's a few con ones to do there's
some mill there's some some aristotle i
might even shoot if i have the time and
the energy some core concept videos that
are not on my current class stuff
but on things like
heidegger's concept of truth
i'm going to be shooting some videos in
the existentialism sequence now that
i've got the ball rolling on chest off
again i want to keep plowing away at his
stuff i've got one more video to shoot
on all things are possible and then i'm
thinking the next work that i'm going to
tackle is probably
his uh dostoevsky and nietzsche
philosophy of tragedy
in addition to shooting some videos on
chest off this month in the
existentialism sequence i want to shoot
some more heidegger videos and i'm going
to be shooting things
not out of being in time
or the nietzsche lectures which i will
get to eventually in the existentialism
sequence but instead some more of the
ones that are in the basic writing so
his response to sart in in
the the piece on humanism
the question concerning technology
those are definitely going to be on the
list
that might be enough for this month
because those might take more than an
hour each to discuss
but there's a lot of things i've got
sort of in the pipes when it comes to
the existentialism sequence
um
i guess the last thing to say about that
is if you are interested specifically in
the existentialist
stuff
you probably want to follow my blog
sandler's existentialist updates because
when i have new stuff available
or when i come across some cool sites
discussions about existentialism
i
talk about it there
but if you don't want to do that you've
got uh my main blog or access do you
know etiquette that you can you can
follow uh and wade through i've been
writing on that for about about uh three
or four years now there's a lot of
entries
all over the map and what they discuss
and
i guess that wraps it up
so um
a lot going on this month
i suppose i should wish you all a happy
thanksgiving in advance
those of you who you know are here in
the states
i believe there's some other
thanksgivings in other places although
i'm not not really that up on that
and um
stay tuned i should have about
20 or 25 new videos coming the rest of
this month and uh
yeah that's a good place to leave